he just took off and ran
i know he's scared out there and breaks
my heart
let's go find him
[Music]
this time on trackers
hope is lost it's very emotional because
it's a scary thing i don't know if she's
okay when a puppy bolts
this is probably the worst place you
could ever have a lost dog into harm's
way
panic sets in i just don't want her to
get hit by a car or train
[Music]
a heat wave has rolled over maryland
those who work outside like anne and her
german shepherd gretel
are smart to start their day before the
sun becomes unbearable griddle is a
three-year-old german shepherd we
started training gretel at eight weeks
old and now she is a fantastic tracking
dog we gotta go work
gretel and her owner ann wills team up
with tracker carmen brothers
i'm gonna help give her some experience
on the job they're responding to a call
a cat's been missing for days poop is a
large gray fluffy cat
she just wants love and it's hard not to
love her she's a very lovable cat
this adorable house cat has had it rough
for most of her life
she was born feral and is fortunate to
have survived this long the first time
that i had met hope she was laying in my
driveway clearly hurt
[Music]
the x-rays showed that there were two
metal pieces in her arm
doctor told me she was shot
the vet said the only option was
amputation he made it very clear that
she could not go outside and if she did
go outside her chances were very very
slow
kelly and her son adopted hope and they
nursed her back to health
two nights ago hope darted out the back
door we miss her she is a part of our
family and we want her home safely
[Music]
kelly is relying on gretel's help to
bring hope home
to do so gretel must acquire hope's
scent
i actually have
a cushion that was very strictly hoped
the one side is completely covered in
nothing but who perfect yes the other
cat did tons and tons of cat hair on
that yes
okay so anybody touch it
[Music]
six
look at me
gretel is one of our most superior
tracking dogs
when i tell her to set up on an article
she takes a quick sniff and off she goes
dog is catching scientific under here
i want to look underneath that shed
gretel's heightened excitement signals a
high concentration of hope scent near
kelly's backyard a possible hiding spot
from sun and predators
regret all
it's possible that hope came through
here and was hiding under the shed for a
little while but i don't think she's
physically there right now we need to
keep tracking i'm going to pass the
leash over to carmen give her all the
leash okay and let her pull she's one of
the lights to be out in front okay okay
let's go
right now
german shepherds are the most common
canine used in police work
including drug interdiction
find a kitty they're known for high
intelligence and desire to work
okay
she definitely keeps going this way
before i rescued hoop she had lived in
these woods
i believe 100 she is with the feral cats
running around in the backwoods here
hope's missing leg makes it difficult to
hunt or escape attacks
this could lead her to seek the security
a feral colony provides
if hope is adopting the social habits of
the colony it will make her harder to
rescue over time
[Music]
gives the signal that the track is over
okay that's the way she indicates good
girl good girl
gretel did indicate strongly that she
was picking up scent in the woods
knowing that hope was once a feral cat
the news is bittersweet for kelly
i'm really afraid that now that hope has
had another taste of freedom out in the
wild that she's not going to want to
come home and it terrifies me
[Music]
there you go
trustee likes her routine which includes
breakfast being on time
on her days off trustee would eat and
hit the sofa
today she's got to go to work stinky old
food breath
once we get out and we're on the road
her ears perk right up she becomes a
little sniffing monster
trustee and her handler wendy are also
headed to baltimore in search of a newly
fostered chihuahua named suzy
when you are a foster family for dogs
there are two things that you don't want
to have happen no one gets hurt on your
watch and no one gets lost it's not a
good feeling
susie has had more than her share of
pain
susie was in a house with 12 other
puppies and they were all in really bad
shape and neglected and animal control
came and they were able to get the
owners to surrender them
we wanted to give susie a safe place to
stay until we could find her a permanent
home
after transporting susie from virginia
jessie let susie out with the other dogs
a mistake he regrets she didn't have a
leash on her collar or anything let her
out of the crate shouldn't have she
bolted through the fence
it happened really fast she's just a
little tiny thing i haven't even met her
yet
we have to find her
today is supposed to be like 90 degrees
plus
little guys like this they get out they
can get dehydrated really fast and end
up in a world of trouble
trustee and wendy start the track at
stacy and jesse's house susie's last
known location all right if you just
want to sit it down
my name
unlike gretel trusty responds to
commands in english not german
tracking is instinctual for trustee and
requires very little direction from
wendy good girl
josie's telling me that the dog has come
through here i can tell by her body
language how she turns her head
chihuahuas are bold explorers but their
size makes them vulnerable to birds of
prey like hawks and owls
trustee just walked us into the
laundromat she's showing that
susie has been through here
i think that susie went into the
laundromat and turned around and went
back out which was a good thing because
there's a seriously big road there so
she gave a really good indication that
susie went in there yep
trustee continues down the block weaving
in and out of yards mapping out susie's
path
trustee's air scenting right now
susie has got to be really really close
trustee is capable of tracking scent
particles left on the ground or using
air currents to detect where ascent is
originating from
it's not a trait shared by all tracking
breeds it creates shortcuts
moments later jesse gets a voicemail
someone spotted susie a block away it's
right here in the backyard of the corner
house of fleetwood the house with a lot
of gardening in the front you can't miss
a whole bunch of bushes in the front
yard
i hope it's her because i really want to
bring her home today so let's go check
it out
[Music]
we need to confirm that this dog is
susie
see a dog
she's here
hey susie doll
hey susie where'd you go
this is the first time susie has ever
seen or heard stacy without any bond
between the two the chihuahua is wary
she was right here
and i could just see her peeking over
and as i moved a little closer she just
disappeared from there
she is behind this house
it's a nightmare back there it's chock
full of all kinds of stuff to hide under
and behind the only thing that i can
suggest at this point is to trap it
because i don't think we're going to get
her any other way
trustee escapes the heat while wendy
places the trap out of the sun
she then mixes cat food with water that
will be used as a chum trail to
hopefully lure susie into the trap
that ought to do it okay
[Music]
my dog's back there now
he's licking the shop
and i'm just hoping he's going to follow
it
until he goes into the trap
[Music]
[Music]
we got her we got her we got her
hi sweetie
hold on we'll get you out of there hello
how did that happen
oh are you kidding me
[Music]
four days ago susie the chihuahua bolted
from her new foster owner's house we had
her for a hot minute she was here maybe
10 minutes before she left the yard we
do know that she just is very afraid of
people
which doesn't make this any easier
[Music]
the team tracked susie to this yard and
set up a trap hold on we'll get you out
of there
the door mechanism failed
something is up with the trap she popped
open and shot out
so here i am no freaking dog
i feel so responsible for this i don't
know how it happened i'm at a loss
trustee is my partner
we're a team i let her down
stacy and jesse are in shock
i saw
susie darting out of the trap
and it was just absolutely devastating
because we were just so very close
susie is in flight mode
there's so many motions going through me
right now
it's so frustrating to see her and not
be able to just go and get her and wrap
her up in my arms and bring her back
[Music]
the best thing i can do right now is try
to set something up to trick
susie so that she'll think it's another
place to hide and she'll come into the
trap after what happened today i don't
think susie's going to go back into a
trap
the broken trap is replaced
and a new plan is devised
i'm going to disguise it as much as
possible so that she won't have a clue
as to where it is or why it's there
[Music]
only thing she's gonna smell is cat food
i won't rest really till we know for
sure she's in the house safely
later that night
susie makes an appearance
this little teeny dog sniffing around
and her back like almost near her butt
hit the door of the trap and set it off
i was worried about susie all night i
didn't sleep at all
trustee and wendy are back on the case
the next morning
what we're working on right now is
getting two traps set back there
i just personally saw her back there and
she bolted
he's not gonna come out any other way
but in that
trap dog is back there
[Music]
oh my goodness look how skinny you are
we caught ourselves a fluffy
i got both sides
okay
i'm so grateful that she's in here
i'm just glad that she she's gonna be
okay
jesse and wendy secure the trap susie's
not going to escape again
i am overwhelmed this whole experience
has been an emotional rollercoaster ride
i lost her words so
just happy she's safe
i'm so grateful that that dog is in the
cage
i felt so bad yesterday and
now i know she's safe and she's gonna be
okay
instead of worrying about her being out
here
on her own
right now i'm feeling pretty excited and
just
100 relieved i do want to meet susie but
again
she's not too happy with people right
now
five days on her own susie's tired and
hungry but otherwise healthy i'm not
scary don't worry
this is the first time susie meets her
foster mom stacy
she doesn't look too bad given that
she's been out since friday night
there is so much relief right now we got
done what we needed to get done and that
was to get her and get her back into a
safe home
you're such a good girl
meanwhile hope a three-legged rescue cat
is still
missing she was an outdoor cat four
years before i had gotten her she knows
the area she knows this area better than
i do there's a chance she could be just
somewhere just hiding bunkering out and
you know an old spot she used to love
gretel tracked her scent to a wooded
area
home to a feral cat colony it's very
emotional because it's a scary thing i
don't know if she's okay
gretel's job is done for now and the
focus shifts to enticing hope out of the
woods get the sheets off your bed
wipe down everybody in the house with
that sheet cut them into little strips
of material
and every say four feet
i want you to drop one of those sun
strips
the bulk of a feral cat's diet is
scavenged not killed cat food is an
ideal bait we're going to set up the
trap almost directly behind kelly's
house on the wood line make sure you put
it all the way in the back so that hope
has to go all the way in
chances are hope is hungry and we've
just set up a gourmet feast
i hope it works but with a feral cat i
just don't i don't feel the odds are in
my favor
an average indoor cat
yes they're going to follow the scent
trail they're going to follow the smell
of the cat food they're going to go into
the trap and get caught
hope's smarter than that
i'm confident that hope is in these
woods the trick is going to be to get
her to come to us by luring her out and
we're gonna have to be patient
we're on hopes time not ours
these woods are home to not only feral
cats but also predators a trail cam will
help carmen confirm that hope is still
roaming this area
i'm really scared for hope
with her only having the three legs she
is vulnerable
wildlife is it's mean it's survival of
the fittest and
sadly she's not the fittest to be able
to survive out there
for jake a high-energy black and tan
coonhound most of his days start with a
workout with his pal gracie
his temperament shifts when it's time to
put on the work vest he's a tracking dog
he loves to work uh blue collar that'd
be a great way to describe jake
good trick jake
jake and tim are responding to a call in
the maryland suburbs
my dog's name is uh jackpot godzilla
carney he's about five years old
he's a boston terrier he's black and
white
he's very friendly
if he sees someone on the street he'll
come right up to him and try to be their
best friend he's a lovable little
character and we miss him unfortunately
the family doesn't know exactly when or
how jack escaped he's been gone about 48
hours
our hope today is to get at least an
idea of the direction he went
this is his
bed he sleeps on it's inside the crate
okay cool
[ __ ] hounds have up to 300 million cent
receptors in their nose humans a mere
six million
jake's sizable ears are an asset they
sweep the lost dog scent into his nose
he gets commands in japanese you're
saying weird stuff okay yeah
english words kind of all sound the same
to a dog so they'll learn quicker if you
have something that is its own
distinctive word and plus the general
public can't tell them to do something i
guess right
when jake picks up the scent article
initially he kind of checks everything
out and goes okay the dog's been here
when he gets out of the perimeter of the
yard that's when i know that he's got it
he's picking up some scent here so i'm
just gonna let him roll all right
i generally trust his first instinct
jake come on
this is the first lead in jack's case
i think it's pretty cool it's
comforting
to know
at least the direction i have somewhere
to focus on
boston terriers do not tolerate heat
well
so seeking shade in the woods seems
plausible so do you think he has a scent
i do yeah
jake is picking up a strong scent here
and i can tell by the way his head is on
the ground and his pace
he's fired up right now
under normal conditions a 20-pound
boston terrier needs roughly two and a
half cups of water daily
with temperatures in the 90s that number
climbs
according to the way jake is tracking
right now it looks like this could be
jack's water source it makes me feel
confident that jack's in the area
by air scenting jake can pick up jack's
scent quickly
it also enables him to track jack
through water and densely wooded areas
a lot of prickers jake what are you
going to do
typically when the dog leaves its home
it's going to do like a one to two mile
radius
[Music]
what does total mean
search
wants to go this way
missing pets often circle the
neighborhood close to their home
jake heads back into the woods retracing
jack's steps
that's where he picked up his heavy
ascent
i'm liking jake's activity for a feeding
station around here
jake picked up jack's scent around the
perimeter of the neighborhood but is
primarily in a wooded area two blocks
from his home
so the action plan right now for jack is
we're gonna put down a feeding station
and a trail cam by the creek line
and see what that turns up a feeding
station is used to lure a missing pet
onto a piece of cardboard covered with
flour and food
if jack visits the feeding station he'll
leave behind paw prints that lead in the
direction of where he is hiding
that's good
hopefully jack will want to come back to
this spot
it's comforting to know where to focus
our search effort hopefully
something will
pop soon
across town trustee and wendy are
responding to a call about a lost puppy
named aspen
she is a boxer labrador mix uh light
brown she's just at that fun stage where
she likes to annoy the other dogs and
nip and play and we've had her a little
over a month kennedy daughter right
after she graduated from high school
rebecca adams is pet sitting aspen for
her daughter kennedy
the dog slipped through the back gate
and disappeared
started looking for her immediately we
put up posters around posted things on
facebook
as you can see we have a cornfield in
mind fear is she went that way
since rebecca has several dogs the scent
article must be exclusively aspen's
the presence of multiple animal scents
will compromise trustees ability to
track the puppy
okay
trustee confirms rebecca's fears aspen's
trail runs between the woods and the
cornfield
[Music]
trustee and i are struggling on this
terrain i can't even think about how
hard it must be for aspen
stickers
hang on
thank you
i'm coming
you've got an advantage there girl
the terrain coming through there was
actually kind of tough you don't know
how difficult it is until you follow 105
dogs but we're doing good
[Music]
okay we're at water now
trustee is trailing aspen's scent
through tough terrain
the temperature is in the mid 90s making
this a life-threatening situation for a
puppy this heat is brutal i'm not
surprised that trusty brought me down to
this creek
i'm sure that little aspen found this
water source and it's very probable that
he's just running the stream
trusty's loose skin around her neck
helps trap and maintain the scent
particles this is a critical asset when
tracking near water
[Music]
no i can't go that
way on you gotta come up here
come on girl
the scent that trusty's following right
now is very fresh
did you see what she just did
she air synthetic here
i can tell because trustee's breathing
is more labor and she's completely
focused on the scent
it looks as though aspen just came
through here
it looks to me like
she came down here and turned back
around
[Music]
aspen is a three-month-old puppy missing
for 24 hours
she's light brown has pretty beautiful
green eyes she's playful as anything
it's like having a little baby
trustees tracked the pup deep into the
woods
trusty was picking up aspen scent so
strong
then the track stopped
aspen is part boxer a breed known for
their stamina
they were used as reliable and tireless
couriers in both world wars
if trustee's on her trail she's at least
three miles from home
[Music]
the scent stopped and didn't pick back
up aspen's been removed from the spot
how i don't know who i don't know but
the dog has been picked up from here
wendy is convinced someone or something
scooped up aspen
the strategy is to have rebecca continue
to put up flyers and spread the word to
nearby residents it hasn't even been 24
hours and aspen left
rebecca has gone and she's put flyers
out all over this area
she's got a great jumpstart if there's
anything that you may have a question
about please call me okay and then
tomorrow just touch base and see if
anything's happened
before wendy's even in her car rebecca
gets a call aspen was found down the
road and she was found it's like
literally right where we were
i'm impressed trustee i mean she knew
what she was doing
you did good
now we're gonna go get my daughter's dog
aspen was retrieved from the same wood
line where trustee ended the track in
the creek you can go
it's like right here
just perfectly
i don't know how you could have done a
better job honestly
[Music]
it's a pretty baby
i was walking the dog and next thing you
know out prance is this little cute
puppy and i was like that looks like the
one on the posters so
i found aspen it's a gratifying feeling
it's great getting these dogs back to
their owners
little trusty track exactly where the
girl picked the dog up
it doesn't get better than this with the
case solved trustee can't resist joining
in the celebration that's who you were
looking for
meanwhile a family still searches for
jack their lost boston terrier
it's frustrating that there's been
absolutely no you know true sightings
jake tracked jack to a small wooded area
in a neighborhood
[Music]
we checked the trail cam and basically
it was a cat some raccoons and a possum
so no sighting of jack
my plan now is for jim to fly up this
area pretty heavy and just bring more
awareness that jacks around here
jake has done everything he can to
isolate jack's location he heads out to
work a case with his other partner
carmen
two-year-old sasha has been missing for
three days
i feel like a big baby over my dog but
i just really we all miss her
i've had her since she was eight weeks
old she's real gentle and sweet i mean
she would never hurt anybody
it was friday morning and the tree
trimmers were out back
and i waited till they were done and i
let my dogs out real quick
not even five minutes later sasha was
nowhere to be found
i blame myself
i thought we'd get her right away
i didn't think it would go on this long
i am willing to do whatever it takes to
get her back
so i think we'll start from the siding
sent jake up and kind of go from there
sasha was last spotted near a trucking
company between railroad tracks and a
busy highway
this is probably the worst place you
could ever have lost dog
so where exactly she was standing on the
railroad tracks and she started to come
this way but then traffic started right
there
okay and she went in the woods okay
i can't put jake on railroad tracks are
you kidding
and this is an active railroad it's not
like
you know and then you got the highway
right there
so there's nowhere
safe to trap or track or anything else
this is the first time carmen has
encountered active railroad tracks and
calls ann wills for advice but it's
gonna be like i don't know five feet
from the tracks i mean the whole thing
is a railroad man you can send jake up
and see where he goes but you have to
keep off those railroad tracks okay you
don't want to flush something out so no
feeding stations or traps near those
railroad tracks okay
kathy's daughter places the scent
article where sasha was spotted last
i'll set him up when i set him up to
stay behind me a little bit
swati
thank you
jake look at me
i'm scared it's really dangerous for me
to track with jake right here
i'm not sure how jake's gonna react if
the train does come flying by
[Music]
it's been three weeks since hope escaped
she jumped the neighbor's fence climbed
up with her three legs somehow
and went for the woods and just been
trying to you know try to get her back
after weeks of uncertainty the trail cam
confirms hope is still alive
my biggest concern is that another
animal is going to get her and she's not
going to be able to defend herself like
she used to
[Music]
went and checked the trail hammocks in a
while
for the first time in weeks kelly sees
her cat hope is alive
when i saw her oh sorry oh i might need
a minute for this one
when i saw her on that camera just pure
excitement
it's a momentary sense of relief
a fox was spotted in the same area
since then no sign of hope
[Music]
anne is coming back so we can track
again we're going to bring the dog back
um try to see if we can pick up her
scents go get the set article okay
we use the dog to check the backyard
again
see if we still get sent she may even
stop okay and say hey
now it's in this part of the woods we'll
pull her into the backyard and catch her
and trap
you
yes
indeed
work
good girl
center off
sit
look at me
where'd he go
where's kitty
bingo
tons of smell
oh yay
she's all over the yard
okay
good girl
[Music]
gretel gave a full alert which means
she's here still
you decoy good job
i'm super excited hope is still here
we're just gonna move the trap slightly
and disguise it a little bit more so we
can get her caught
all right so let's set these traps
they won't get lucky tonight i was about
to say i might wake up tomorrow and have
my little kitty cat back
[Music]
okay
jake continues searching the train
tracks in pursuit of sasha the rescue
mutt
it's just
a terrible situation and she's such a
young little sweet dog i
i'm terrified for i really really am
terrified i just don't want her to get
hit by a car or train
he's focused on his target and pulls
carmen across the tracks into a small
patch of woods
i'm going to try and get a read on
whether the dogs might be in the woods
or if she took off running down the
tracks
oh god please let us get her
[Music]
jake's not picking up a lot of scent
here that makes me more confident that
sasha's running the train tracks and not
hunker down in this area of woods
come on sasha
okay come on let's go
the location is frustrating
you know bring forth all this effort
we're not getting much of any result
the action plan is going to be a fire up
unfortunately with the area we're in
it's so dangerous i can't do scent
trails or a feeding station or even a
trap
flyer like obnoxiously right through
here we just gotta get another sighting
and i'm just like
flipping it but we're doing everything
we can i just thought it would be we're
going to put traps here we're going to
do this well it's just i can't
i really can't put up traps here in good
conscious just because i'd be putting
sasha's life in danger
i'm very worried about sasha my main
case right now is her safety
i know kathy's very frustrated right now
but we're doing all the right things and
it will happen
their only option is to put up flyers
and wait for someone to spot sasha and
provide a new clue to this mystery
jack the boston terrier has been missing
for almost a week he's a very lovable
dog if he sees someone on the street
he'll come right up to him and try to be
their best friend he'll want to go into
some people's houses he has no fear of
people
jake isolated the search area to a small
patch of woods three miles from jack's
home
flyers were distributed but there have
been no signs of jack
until now
jack bryant
good boy
we've got a call from somebody that
found him saw one of the signs that we
put up
we're feeling great we're glad to have
him back
he lost a lot of weight he's definitely
scratched up
a little gun shy at everything really
but we think he's going to be good
jake let us very close to where he was
found he did a great job and we're
thankful for that
i figured he was either gone or with
somebody and
the person didn't want to turn him in
a good samaritan picked jack up a little
over a mile from his house
i feel like jake has a gift and we help
reunite somebody with their pets and
that's just it feels awesome
sasha the rescue mutt has been on the
run for four days
it's like losing a major part of our
family we are really centered around our
family and our dogs
jake tracks sasha to a precarious
location i've never seen such a
challenging location you're literally
cornered by highway and railroads
my main case right now is her safety
after carmen and sasha's owner kathy put
up flyers a sighting was called in
we are on our way back to kathy's house
she got a positive sighting right there
at the train tracks uh last night so we
are trying to get out there as early as
possible today
and get jake out and get him you know
see if he picks up scent
and do some perimeter searches and kind
of see where we go from there
the sighting is just north of the train
tracks where jake showed the most
interest
carmen and jake are investigating the
area with kathy and her daughter
thank you
right now we're doing um perimeter
checks
to see if we can like kind of pinpoint
an area that sasha might have come out
onto
we're just you know trying to pick up
scent in general to narrow down areas so
we can focus in on one
last night my daughter and i walked the
tracks from one end down there to all
the way down the other end and called
her and sat
we didn't see anything
he's still looking he's air centering as
well as brown sending
like you know he put his nose through
the gate a couple times
waiting to see if he picks up scent
he keeps looking off that way i think
this is where we started yesterday
and you can see he's trying to still
pick up the scent as his nose goes up in
the air and i can't let him on those
come on jake sosa
so
no real strong scent
jake did not pick up any scent really
which leads me to believe that
sasha is still kind of hunkered down in
that one area to the right of the train
tracks or it's i mean it's always a
possibility that sasha's been picked up
i don't think she's here anymore i hope
she's not
perhaps she went back in the
neighborhood
which is why i want you to get flyers
all through i mean like obnoxiously fire
yesterday i was really upset about it
but today i feel a little bit better
because i'm
hoping it means she's not here anymore
and this is such a little dangerous
place
a large part of finding your dog is the
community outreach somebody's obviously
seeing your dog we just need to find
that one person
so i strongly advise her to put up
flyers throughout the entire area now
it's a waiting game
fingers crossed
[Music]
four days later sasha is spotted on the
train tracks again
we just got a call that there has been a
sighting of sasha
we are going to go out and see if we can
bring sasha home
when carmen arrives she's shocked to see
a surprise guest
[Music]
hi
hi
we found her finally
after carmen and kathy put out flyers
there was a sighting of sasha
we got partway down the tracks and saw
sasha at the other end just staring at
us and katie went up and got sasha this
has been like my life looking for her
for the last eight days
so
we can finally all sleep tonight a whole
night
i'm so happy for you oh i can't wait to
get her home good job
thank you
couldn't be a happier ending when i saw
them together it was perfect i mean you
couldn't ask for a happier outcome
i know i can't wait to get you home
yes i can't wait
hope the three-legged cat has been
missing for over a month
i just saw hope on the trail cam footage
i am just so excited to know that she is
still alive
ann wills is trying a different larger
cage to see if that could help secure
hope
three days
[Music]
in the pass finally
when i went out to the cage at first i
didn't know it was her
then i started hearing this like howling
noise almost like a fox i've never heard
it oh that's real distressed yes and i
looked up and she popped her head up and
i was like wow
i started freaking out
after a month 39 days exactly and she
looks good
hi you are miracle you are
gretel thank you so so much
i'm so excited to have my baby back home
gretel did a great job she was very
consistent with it and gave us
directions where she was and seeing
where hope came from gretel was
definitely on it oh she's so lovable
i am so happy and i'm proud of all the
effort everybody did i'm proud of what
carmen did with gretel
and i am just ecstatic
[Music]
you